carrusel de las artes
[Música]
maría carolina piña
bienvenidos sean todos a este programa
especial que dedicamos hoy al padre del
teatro francés carrusel de las artes
conmemora hoy los 400 años del natalicio
de moldear la ocasión para descubrir las
claves de su obra y su legado a la
literatura y las artes escénicas
[Música]
mole ajo el artífice de un teatro para
divertir autor de comedias y farsas que
sirvieron para hacer una ácida crítica a
la sociedad del siglo 17 visitaremos la
comedia francés de la compañía de teatro
más prestigiosa de francia heredera y
defensora del repertorio de molière e
iremos también a peu senasa ciudad
medieval donde morías trabajo y encontró
la inspiración para crear personajes y
situaciones picarescas que
revolucionaron el mundo del teatro
[Música]
francia celebra en 2022 a uno de sus
autores más ilustres john batista porque
la mejor conocido como molière quien
inventó en el siglo 17 una forma inédita
de comedia basada en la parodia de las
costumbres y los vicios de su época
i
[Música]
bajo el protectorado del bis 14 el rey
sol molida se convirtió en el
entretenedor de la corte escribió en
total 35 obras que han sido traducidas
en numerosos idiomas
[Música]
me temo
y
ver las piezas de molière forman parte
del repertorio clásico y para hablarnos
de esta obra tenemos cita con el
historiador marcial paso uno de los
mayores especialistas de molière en
francia muchísimas gracias más hacia el
corazón por estar con nosotros en
carrusel de las artes cuéntanos cuál es
para usted el lugar que ocupa molía en
la literatura francesa golias setara fue
con formato yunier fue un gran
reformador de la manera de actuar para
el teatro fue un actor formidable que
defendió la actuación natural dejó atrás
las convenciones para dedicarse a
reproducir y para odiar a la sociedad
fue también un escritor genial inventó
la comedia moderna en verso y en prosa
su teatro se liberó del formalismo del
drama y de la tragedia para hablar de lo
que ocurría en su época se suele decir
que pintó en el teatro a los principales
arquetipos sociales
y
la familia alma fue uno de los artífices
de la política artística de luis 14 el
rey sol y de la proyección cultural de
francia dentro y fuera de sus fronteras
y ahora en sus farsas en sus comedias
molidas describió la época y denunció
los vicios de su época por ejemplo la
avaricia la hipocresía la corrupción es
un autor moralista fue un autor
moralista molía como llega
para muriera el teatro debía divertir
hacer reír pero para educar creía que la
risa era el medio para enseñarle a la
humanidad a reconocer vicios como la
avaricia la misantropía la ambición
molière atacó directamente la
institución más poderosa de su época la
iglesia por eso se ganó numerosos
enemigos en las altas esferas religiosas
los cuales hicieron todo lo posible para
prohibir sus obras esto ocurrió en 1664
con el tartufo y un año después con el
donjuán considerada una pieza atea la
esencia del teatro de moliere es la
crítica de la autoridad y del abuso del
poder
esto es una característica muy moderna
lo cual explica sin duda en la
actualidad que sigue teniendo su obra en
nuestros días
moliére creó su propia compañía en
1643 el ilustre teatro para el cual
actuó y escribió sus obras tras la
muerte del autor el ilustre teatro se
asoció a otra compañía para fundar la
comedia francesa en
1680 compañía que sigue en actividad
la comedia francesa tiene un repertorio
de 3.000 obras aunque las demolidas
están presentes en cada temporada piezas
que inmortalizaron a personajes como
argán tartufo harpagón en la casa de
molière conversamos con dos actores de
la comedia francesa julie chica y javi
lópez fue de comedia comedy fons es un
exitoso ser actor o actriz en la comedia
con cesc es muy exigente el público nos
reclama hacer excelentes todos tenemos
esa ambición para los actores el hecho
de actuar todos los días de la semana
sin descanso los sábados y domingos dos
veces por día significa que vivimos como
atletas sumidos en una gimnasia intensa
pero eso nos permita alcanzar esa
excelencia es muy exigente y al mismo
tiempo es un brujo un lujo supremo
griego
standing molière es un genio que dejó a
los artistas la libertad de interpretar
sus piezas cada quien a su manera cada
pieza cada personaje acepta miles de
lecturas posibles y su humor además
tiene muchas capas a veces molière es un
drama absoluto pero para entender eso
hace falta tiempo pero cuando se llega a
ese punto moliére es sublime nunca
y diputación
y yo
de la unión
mi personaje favorito es planet la
sirvienta en el enfermo imaginario' ese
rol ha sido un regalo del teatro en sus
piezas los sirvientes los lacayos o los
más inocentes son quienes transmiten el
conocimiento popular y el sentido común
por eso actúan et es un pilar
para mí el mejor personaje masculino
demolía es escapan él es el criado
astuto un poco font quien concentra todo
el genio humorístico de molière escapan
es el tipo que sufrió todos los males
que fue casi un esclavo pero que es
capaz de decir odio a esos corazones
pusilánimes que tratando de anticipar
todo no emprenden nada está hablando de
las personas que tienen miedo de todo
del que dirán que no logran avanzar en
la vida
y bueno
se activa cueto desde
sí
[Música]
la comedia 11 se conserva un objeto que
es considerado como una reliquia el
sillón de molière la conservadora de la
casa haga de san juan nos habló de este
objeto inestimable que forma parte de
los fondos de la biblioteca museo de la
comedia francesa son este mueble es el
sillón de molière parece increíble pero
si es verdad en este sillón molière
interpretó el último rol de su vida el
rol de argán en el enfermo imaginario'
molière actuó tres veces y en la cuarta
representación tuvo un acceso de todos
que obligó a suspender la función poco
después se murió de tuberculosis el
sillón pasó entonces a la historia y de
hecho se utilizó durante casi 200 años
hasta 1879 después se decidió colocarlo
en una vitrina para que los espectadores
se pudieran verlo todas las noches
[Música]
poco a poco la comedia hansen se terminó
llamándose la casa demolida es el teatro
que más representaciones hace de las
obras demolidas en todo el mundo son
miles y miles de representaciones desde
su fundación
parís o versalles son lugares donde
molidas alcanzó un gran éxito pero en el
sur de francia una pequeña ciudad
medieval puede hacer alarde de un gran
vínculo con el dramaturgo francés se
trata de pez en as donde se conserva
otros y yo de molière vamos a hallar de
la mano de melisa barra
en sus inicios la obra de molière no
tuvo mucho éxito en parís por lo que el
joven dramaturgo se fue de la ciudad y
durante 13 años viajó por toda francia
vivió en psoe nace una pequeña ciudad de
la región occitana de long dog en tres
ocasiones la primera fue en
sabemos que vino aquí en
1650 porque tenemos en los archivos
departamentales tenemos un recibo que
cuenta que vino aquí y organizó esas
fiestas para algunos días algunas
semanas
[Aplausos]
tu mente
sabemos que se fue varias veces en esa
tienda a la tienda del bar biel y el
lugar donde se encontraba casi toda la
ciudad y el pueblo de la ciudad de penas
ese barbero tenía un sillón y se dice
que molière se sentaba en ese sillón
para mirar a la gente al pueblo dp cenas
se dice que eso influyó mucho para crear
una obra que se llama el señor de por
sonia que ese ambiente la gente que
existía en esa época es una obra mayor
para nosotros porque se habla en el
idioma que se hablaba por la época que
era el occitano y molière aprendió el
occitano
en fin de cuentas muy bien permaneció en
presionadas por cortos periodos
invitados por el príncipe de contigo
pero dejó en la ciudad una huella
imborrable hace doscientos años amantes
de su obra encontraron en archivos
rastros de su paso y decidieron
homenajearlo en las calles ese siglo 19
es el siglo donde se desarrolló el
movimiento importante que se llama el
molière ismo vamos a reconocer a partir
de ese siglo que molière es la persona
importante en la literatura en el teatro
francés entonces se organizó fue creada
una comisión para financiar un monumento
dedicado a molière y está constituida
con el busto de molière encima del
monumento después a la izquierda tenemos
una mujer que está ofreciendo unas
flores al busto a muller y ese es el
personaje de louis sets es la sirviente
la doncella de la obra del señor de por
sonia que entonces está a la izquierda
del otro lado
entonces a la derecha tenemos un sátiro
entonces una mezcla entre un hombre y
una
cabra es el símbolo de la farsa es el
símbolo que representa la comedia
personal se acoge todos los años un
festival de teatro a la gloria de
molière y se ha vuelto un lugar de
peregrinación para comediantes de todo
el país
[Música]
gracias melisa barra y molida murió en
1670 y tres días después de desplomarse
en el escenario cuando interpretaba el
enfermo imaginario' una muerte trágica
que acrecentó la leyenda de morir
hoy en día los máximos galardones del
teatro francés se llaman los molidas
premios que se entregan desde 1987
aquí ponemos punto final este programa
especial carrusel de las artes es
dedicado a molière en el 400 aniversario
de su nacimiento muchísimas gracias por
su sintonía
[Música]